c'est la mélodie qui annoncent l'arrivée
des éboueurs le ballet quotidien du
ramassage des ordures
les citoyens apportent eux mêmes leurs
sacs à ordures leur recyclage et leurs
restes de table
un chaos chorégraphié au son de lettre à
élise de beethoven mais il y a des
règles de conduite rappel cette femme
venue porter ses déchets avec sa fille
les gens s'énervent si on ne fait pas la
file correctement dit m
[Musique]
personne n'y échappe même les petits
commerçants comme celui ci doivent
apporter leurs déchets pour la collecte
ça fait partie de son travail le camion
passe deux fois par soir
et si l'on ne vit pas tout près d'un
point de collecte cet homme doit marcher
trois coins de rue pour apporter cet
échec aux attendes codem pénètre tous
les soirs s'en faut
chaque fois celui ci arrive tout avec
ses sacs à ordures pour croiser amis et
voisins d'aqaba femme n'a été épargné il
c'est l'occasion de se mettre à jour sur
les nouvelles et rumeurs du quartier
communiqué
apportez soi même ses ordures ou camions
favorise l'esprit communautaire nouaceur
responsable même si la majorité des
taiwanais rencontrés disent qu'il s'agit
plutôt d'une tâche ménagère de plus
cette façon un peu ludique de
responsabiliser les taiwanais et de les
sensibiliser à la protection
environnementale a déjà 25 ans
auparavant dans les années 90 brown
était souvent surnommée l'île aux
déchets
les citoyens paient une taxe déguisée
pour leur volume de déchets seuls les
sacs à ordures gouvernementaux sont
permis il faut donc les acheter legrand
coûte l'équivalent de 20 cents et le
petit 800
lits les brûlures et l'espace pour les
déchets très limité explique-t-il il
fallait offrir un incitatif pour les
citoyens - vous produisez de déchets -
ça vous coûte cher en achats de sacs
depuis l'instauration de ce nouveau
système à taipei en 1998 le taux de
recyclage est passé d'environ deux
ennemis % à 60 % à tony il faut
cependant que les municipalités arrive à
tous recyclés premier cet expert il y à
un goulot d'étranglement depuis quelques
années
le réflexe pavlovien aujourd'hui si fort
à taïwan n'entendrez jamais 700 pense à
sortir ses ordures chaque fois que
l'entente la mélodie de beethoven peu
importe le contexte
[Musique]
cette valse des déchets est profondément
ancré dans le quotidien des taiwanais
ici philippe leblanc radio canada taipei
[Musique]